TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE --
HANDED OVER.
TONIGHT, EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
NEEDS TO BE ASKING WHAT DOES ROD
ROSENSTEIN HIDE IN?
JOINING US NOW FOR AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW, THE FORMER MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY, HE'S A FORMER
ATTORNEY FOR THE PRESIDENT, RUDY
GIULIANI IS WITH US.
>> NICE TO BE BACK.
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN THROUGH A
LOT TOGETHER.
THE CITIES STILL BENEFITING.
GIVE US THE STATUS OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD
LIKE TO INTERVIEW THE PRESIDENT,
EVERY LAWYER IN AMERICA THINKS
HE SHOULDN'T BE.
NOW OUR NEW COLLEAGUE, EMMETT --
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DECIDE,
HERE'S WHAT THE     IT'S ALL ABO
HERE'S WHAT THE     IT'S ALL ABT
HERE'S WHAT THE     IT'S ALL ABA
HERE'S WHAT THE     IT'S ALL ABD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN FOLLOW
THIS ALONG WITH ME -- ARE THEY
OBJECTIVE.
ARE THEY?
A LOT OF THINGS POINT IN THE
DIRECTION THAT JAMES COMEY IS
TELLING THE TRUTH AND NOT THE
PRESIDENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT
THINK, WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT
FEEL, WHAT IS HE REALLY DESIRE?
THOSE ARE ALL QUESTIONS INTENDED
TO TRAP HIM IN SOME WAY AND
CONTRADICTING WHAT IS IN FACT A
VERY, VERY SOLID EXPLANATION OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
HE FIRED AT COMEY COMEY WOULD
NOT -- AMONG OTHER THINGS -- SAY
THAT HE WASN'T A TARGET OF THE
INVESTIGATION IS ENTITLED THAT.
HILLARY CLINTON GOT THAT AND HE
COULDN'T GET THAT.
HE FIRED HIM AND HE SAID I'M
FREE OF THIS GUY AND HE WENT ON
LESTER HOLT, LESTER HOLT'S
INTERVIEW WAS AS GOOD AS ANYBODY
COULD DO, BETTER THAN I THINK
ANY OF THE PEOPLE AROUND MUELLER
COULD HAVE DONE.
HE ASKED THEM WHY DID YOU DO IT?
HE SAID I DID IT BECAUSE I FELT
I HAD TO THE EXPLAINED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS NOT THE TARGET OF
THE INVESTIGATION.
EVEN JAKE TAPPER PUSHED HIM
REALLY HARD, COMEY HAD NO ANSWER
FOR WHY HE DIDN'T SAY THIS.
I DON'T EXPECT WERE GOING TO
HAVE AN INTERVIEW WITH -- I
WOULD LIKE TO GET ONE NOT UNDER
OATH.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY DON'T
MISREPRESENT HIS ANSWERS BUT
THIS IS AN OUTRAGEOUS
MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE.
PLEASE CONSIDER WHETHER YOU ARE
A REPUBLICAN OR A DEMOCRAT,
OR YOU LOVE HIM LIKE WE DO OR
LIKE I DO.
SPARE HIM I THINK PEOPLE KNOW
I'M PRETTY SUPPORTIVE.
I THINK THE SECRET IS OUT OF THE
BAG.
>> I WANT TO LET YOU OUT OF THE
HOOK.
>> Sean: FULL DISCLOSURE, RUDY
GIULIANI AND I ONCE HAD A MEAL
TOGETHER.
>> YOU CAN'T POSSIBLY NOT FEEL
AS A CITIZEN OF THE WORLD THAT
HIS NEGOTIATIONS WITH
NORTH KOREA ARE MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN THIS TOTALLY
GARBAGE INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK ABOUT THE
LEGAL TEAM.
TY COBB, JOHN DOWD, THEY ARE
OUT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS TY COBB HAS
BEEN SAYING FOR SOME TIME HE WAS
GOING TO RETIRE.
>> HE HAS BEEN ENORMOUSLY
HELPFUL, HE HELPED ME WITH MY
ORIENTATION.
WE WOULDN'T BE WHERE WE ARE
TODAY WHICH IS IN A VERY STRONG
POSITION IF IT WASN'T FOR HIM
AND JOHN.
JOHN HAS BEEN MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FOR 35 YEARS, I HAVE
NOTHING BUT THE UTMOST RESPECT
FOR JOHN DOWD.
HE HAD THE RIGHT INSTINCT ABOUT
THIS WHICH IS YOU'RE GOING TO
GET HIM TO TESTIFY OVER MY DEAD
BODY BECAUSE HE'S TRYING TO TRAP
HIM.
HE HAD THE INSTINCT TO SEE THAT.
ALL THAT WORK DIDN'T GO FOR
NOTHING, WE GOT IT ALL.
JAY SEKULOW HAS BEEN THE ROCK.
I COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT HIM.
I OFFER SOMETHING UNIQUE, I'M A
LAWYER WHO KNOWS THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
ANYBODY IN AMERICA.
I'M ALSO A VERY GOOD FRIEND OF
DONALD TRUMP.
AND I THINK I HAVE THE
RESPECTIVE MUELLER, THE FBI, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
JEFF SESSIONS WAS MY COLLEAGUE.
NOT JUST IN THE CAMPAIGN BUT IT
IN 1981 WOULD HE WAS ATTORNEY IN
ALABAMA.
THEY NOTE THE DECISIONS I'M
GOING TO MAKE ARE GOING TO BE IN
THE BEST INTEREST NOT JUST OF MY
CLIENT BUT IN THE UNITED STATES.
AS THEY ARE OBJECTIVE, WE CAN
WORK SOMETHING OUT.
IF THEY'RE NOT, THEN WE HAVE TO
SHAKE HANDS AND GO INTO A
LITIGATION OVER DO THEY HAVE THE
POWER TO SUBPOENA?
I THINK THEY'VE LOST THAT POWER.
INVESTIGATION.
>> YOU HAVE AN INVESTIGATION IN
WHICH MUELLER IS SELECTED TO THE
DAY AFTER HE'S TURNED DOWN FOR
FBI DIRECTOR BY ROD ROSENSTEIN
WHO WAS THERE WHEN MUELLER WAS
TURNED DOWN.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO COULD HAVE BEEN SELECTED FOR
THAT JOB ALSO A FRIEND OF JAMES
COMEY AND HE SEEMS TO BE THE
CORE OF THEIR INVESTIGATION.
I KNOW JAMES COMEY, I KNOW THE
PRESIDENT.
SORRY, JIM, YOU'RE A LIAR.
A DISGRACEFUL LIAR, EVERY FBI
AGENT IN AMERICA HAS HIS HEAD
DOWN BECAUSE OF YOU.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN GOOD IF GOD
WOULD'VE KEPT YOU OUT OF BEING
HEAD OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: EXPLAIN WHERE HE
LIED.
>> HE LIED ABOUT HIS
CONVERSATION WITH ANDREW
McCABE, McCABE SHOULD
TESTIFY AGAINST THEM.
HE ONLY TOLD THE TRUTH WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID -- WE KNOW DONALD
DONALD, IT WAS DONALD BEFORE --
HE LIED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
TALKED ABOUT WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT WAS A SUBJECT OR A
TARGET AND HE IMMEDIATELY
CHANGED IT.
IT'S ONE LIE AFTER ANOTHER.
>> Sean: ROD ROSENSTEIN
EVERYBODY FORGETS WHEN HE WROTE
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO FIRE
COMEY, HE SAID THE FBI CANNOT BE
REESTABLISHED IF HE STAYED.
>> BECAUSE HE'S A LIAR.
HIS CONDUCT OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION
WAS A TOTAL DISGRACE.
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD BEEN
ELECTED PRESIDENT, HE WOULDN'T
HAVE LASTED PAST DAY ONE, WE
KNOW SHE WOULD HAVE FIRED HIM.
I DON'T THINK SHE WOULD EVEN
DENY THAT TODAY.
SHE WAS RIGHT, WE SHOULD HAVE
FIRED HIM, WHEN I SAY WE, I MEAN
THE COLLECTIVE WE, DAY ONE.
LET ME SAY ONE OTHER THING.
THIS IS OUR BEST PRESIDENT IN MY
MEMORY.
EVEN MY HERO RONALD REAGAN, HE
STRAINED THE ECONOMY OUT THE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
BUT HE DIDN'T GET THIS FAR AHEAD
ON FOREIGN POLICY AS FAST AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS.
LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
NORTH KOREA.
I TOLD THE PRESIDENT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET THE NOBEL PEACE
PRIZE AND MY PROUDEST MOMENT IS
WHEN YOU TELL THEM TO SHOVE IT.
SORRY.
>> Sean: THIS IS CABLE, YOU
ARE GOOD HERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LEAK
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE BEEN HERE IN FRONT OF ME,
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT JIM
COMEY, WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT
JEFF SESSIONS.
>> CALL ME SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
FOR LEAKING CONFIDENTIAL FBI
INFORMATION WHEN HE LEAKED HIS
REPORT INTENDED TO DEVELOP A
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
I HAVE NEVER TURNED OVER -- YOU
KNOW ME EVEN WHEN I WAS A U.S.
ATTORNEY.
I NEVER LEAKED A THING.
I WOULD'VE CONSIDERED RESIGNING
IF I EVER DID THAT OR IF ONE OF
MY ASSISTANTS DID IT.
DID THE FBI LEAK, DID THE SEC
LEAK, I'M SORRY GUYS, YOU DID.
>> Sean: THERE IS SO MANY
DERSHOWITZ, OUR OWN
GREGG JARRETT.
THEY SAID THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
NEVER SPEND A MINUTE.
YOU SAID IT WOULD BE NARROW IN
FOCUS AND YOU SAID NO MORE THAN
TWO OR THREE HOURS.
DO YOU BELIEVE ROBERT MUELLER IS
SETTING A PERJURY TRAP FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> I HAVE TO REMAIN OPEN-MINDED
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH
YOU MIGHT NOT SEE A CLEAR AVENUE
TO QUICKLY RESOLVING THIS, WE
SEEK A RESOLUTION THAT GETS A
CLEAR PATH TO GETTING RESOLVED.
I WOULD SAY RIGHT NOW THE ODDS
ARE HE WOULDN'T BUT I DON'T
CLOSE MY MIND TO IT.
>> Sean: WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT -- THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SUBPOENA
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SUBPOEN
SUBPOENA.
IN THE SUBPOENA MEANS THE
PRESENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE HILLARY STANDARD -- THE
HILLARY STANDARD IS SIMPLE --
NOT UNDER OATH.
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU HAVE A GUY
THAT HATES HILLARY AND LOVES
DONALD TRUMP DURING THE
INTERVIEW, THAT WOULD BE THE
HILLARY STANDARD.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> WERE NOT GOING TO GET THAT,
COULD WE ACCEPT SOMETHING LESS
THAN THAT, YES.
COULD WE ACCEPT A SITUATION IN
WHICH THEY ARE TELLING US WE
BELIEVE COMEY WHO WAS NOW A
PATHOLOGICAL LIAR AS OPPOSED TO
DONALD TRUMP, THE ANSWER TO THAT
IS NO.
>> Sean: I HAVE BEEN THE MOST
OUTSPOKEN LOUDEST CRITIC IN THE
COUNTRY BESIDES THE PRESIDENT A
LOT ROBERT MUELLER.
A TEAM OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS, NO
REPUBLICANS.
PEOPLE SAY HE'S A REPUBLICAN AND
A VETERAN, I APPLAUD HIM FOR
SERVING HIS COUNTRY, I MEAN THAT
SERVING HIS COUNTRY, I MEAN THA
THAT.
ANDREW WEISSMANN, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LOST THEIR
JOB AT ENRON.
A 9-0 DECISION AGAINST ANDREW
WEISSMANN, WHO GETS 9-0.
FOR MERRILL LYNCH EXECUTIVES,
OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH CIRCUIT
OF APPEALS, HE'S EXCORIATED
TWICE FOR WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
THAT APPOINTMENT ALONE TELLS ME
THIS IS A BIASED TEAM.
>> LET ME GIVE YOU TWO DIFFERENT
VIEWS OF BOB.
WHAT DO I KNOW THAT I COULD
TESTIFY UNDER OATH?
HE'S A PATRIOT, NEXT WERE NEARLY
GOOD MAN, SERVE HIS COUNTRY.
DID A GOOD JOB WITH THE FBI.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY MALICE OR PREJUDICE,
HOWEVER, I DON'T HAVE AN
EXPLANATION FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
HE HIRED -- NOT ALL OF THEM,
I'VE DEALT WITH THEM VERY
BRIEFLY, I THINK THEY ARE VERY
PROFESSIONAL.
I DIDN'T DEAL WITH ANDREW
WEISSMANN MUCH.
>> Sean: A DISTURBED BY HIS
RECORD?
>> YEAH, BUT HE WOULD BE
DISTURBED BY MINE.
I HAVE AN OPEN MIND ABOUT BOB, I
DON'T ABOUT COMEY.
I KNOW COMEY MUCH BETTER, I HAVE
THE INDIGNITY OF HAVING HIRED
HIM FOR HIS FIRST BIG JOB AND
I'M EMBARRASSED THAT I HIRED HIM
I'M EMBARRASSED THAT I HIRED HI
HIM.
>> Sean: HE TWEETED JOHN DOWD,
THIS ISN'T SOME GAME YOU'RE
SCREWING WITH THE WORK OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
NORTH KOREA, CHINA, THE
MIDDLE EAST, SO MUCH MORE.
THERE IS NOT MUCH TIME TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS ESPECIALLY
SINCE THERE IS NO RUSH OF
COLLUSION.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON, HOW MANY
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS?
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION, HOW DID
WE END UP I'M THERE TO STORMY
DANIELS?
>> I THINK THIS IS BEING DONE
BEHIND A MUELLER'S BACK, BECAUSE
THEY COME TO HIM --
>> Sean: HE DOESN'T READ A
NEWSPAPER?
>> THIS HAS BECOME A WITCH HUNT
THE PRESIDENT SAID.
IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE QUESTIONS,
THEY ARE TRAP QUESTIONS.
A FIRST-YEAR PROSECUTOR WOULD DO
BETTER THAN THAT.
HE'S IN VERY GOOD HANDS, I DON'T
JUST MEET ME, I MEAN JAY AND THE
WHOLE TEAM AND TY COBB GETS A
GREAT DEAL OF CREDIT FOR THIS,
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH EMMETT WHO HANDLES THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN BUSH, THIS IS NOT A
POLITICAL GUY.
>> Sean: HE SAID IF THEY ARE
OBJECTIVE, WE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
COOPERATE.
IF THEY ARE LESS OBJECTIVE, WE
WOULD BE FOOLISH TO DO THAT.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE THEY WOULD
TAKE MUCH LONGER, IT'S COMING TO
A HEAD RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S NOT MUCH MORE TO THINK
ABOUT.
IF THEY CAN GET US IN A POSITION
WHERE WE RECOMMENDED TO THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF HE DOESN'T IT'S GOING TO BE
BECAUSE JAY AND I AND OTHERS SAY
NO.
WILL STAND UP THERE AND SAY WE
ARE LAWYERS, YOU'VE GOT TO
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK I AM THERE BECAUSE I'M
HIS FRIEND.
>> Sean: I THINK YOUR
BACKGROUND AS AN ATTORNEY ALL
THE YEARS AND MAYOR  -- I AGREE
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT.
I HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN AND SAYING
THAT THIS IS A SETUP, THIS IS A
SUBPOENA, THIS IS A PERJURY TRAP
AND LET'S WALK THROUGH WHAT IF
THEY ISSUE A SUBPOENA.
WHAT IF THEY DECIDED NOT TO
TALK, THEY SEND HIM BEFORE A
GRAND JURY BECAUSE IT BECOMES
TRICKY AS ALAN DERSHOWITZ HAS
DESCRIBED ON THIS SHOW.
IF THE PRESIDENT PLEADS THE
FIFTH WHICH HE DOESN'T WANT TO
DO, HE SAID HE DOESN'T WANT TO
DO, THEN THEY GIVE HIM
IMMUNITY -- THEN WHAT?
>> I THINK ALAN POINTED THIS OUT
LAST NIGHT BUT NOT IN DETAIL.
IF THEY ISSUE A SUBPOENA, THAT
WILL BE UNPRECEDENTED IN THE
SENSE THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT A
PRESIDENT CAN'T BE SUBPOENAED TO
A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING ABOUT HIM.
WHY IS THAT?
FORTUNATELY OR MAYBE
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A REAL
LIFE CIRCUMSTANCE GOING ON THAT
THE FOUNDING FATHERS THOUGHT
ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT BE
DISTRACTED BY A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
YOU CAN ALWAYS PROSECUTE HIM
AFTER, THEY CAN GET HIM WHEN HE
LEAVES THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS PROSECUTE HIM
AFTER BUT IF MUELLER TO    SAIDT
AFTER BUT IF MUELLER TO    SAIDO
AFTER BUT IF MUELLER TO    SAIDM
AFTER BUT IF MUELLER TO    SAIDE
TOMORROW BRING HIM IN TWO HOURS,
NO QUESTIONS YOU DON'T WANT AND
WE ARE READY TO CLEAR HIM, I
COULD NOT GO TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND SAY TAKE
TWO DAYS OFF TO GET READY FOR
THAT AND SCREW THE WHOLE THING
WITH NORTH KOREA.
HOW CAN ANY AMERICAN DO THAT?
HE'S OUR PRESIDENT.
HE IS GOING TO NEGOTIATE I
BELIEVE A NONNUCLEAR SITUATION
ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
>> Sean: NOBODY THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO INTERFERE
WITH THAT?
THAT'S WHY THE FOUNDING FATHERS
CREATED TO THIS IMMUNITY FROM
PROSECUTION AND SUBPOENA.
IF IT'S A CIVIL CASE, CLINTON
SUBMITTED BECAUSE OF THE CIVIL
CASE.
>> Sean: WERE NOT WRITTEN
ANSWERS?
>> WHICH RONALD REAGAN DID.
>> Sean: WHY NOT THAT?
>> THEY SAID NO TO THAT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT SAYS --
AND THEY'RE GOING TO WHAT?
>> AT THIS POINT I'M NOT SURE I
WOULD GIVE WRITTEN ANSWERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO
CONTRADICT THEM.
I BELIEVE THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
SESSIONS AND ROSENSTEIN WHO I
DON'T KNOW, I BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE AND THIS INVESTIGATION.
THERE'S BEEN TOO MUCH GOVERNMENT
MISCONDUCT.
THE CRIMES NOW HAVE ALL BEEN
COMMITTED BY THE GOVERNMENT AND
THEIR AGENTS.
THE LIES BY COMEY.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THE
PARAMETERS YOU WOULD INSIST ON
WITH MOLAR IN 2-3 HOURS.
>> NEVER BEYOND 2-3 HOURS.
I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE MY CLIENT,
MY PRESIDENT, MY FRIEND -- I'M
NOT GOING TO LET HIM BE TREATED
WORSE THAN BILL CLINTON WHO
DEFINITELY WAS A LIAR UNDER OATH
DEFINITELY WAS A LIAR UNDER OAT
OATH.
HE'S BEING TREATED MUCH WORSE
THAN HILLARY CLINTON WHO HAD NO
RIGHT TO ANY OF THAT STUFF.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET HIM BE
TREATED WORSE THAN
HILLARY CLINTON.
I THINK JAY AND I WILL INSIST
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TREAT
HIM THE SAME WAY AS CLINTON, TWO
AND A HALF HOURS, THEY END, WE
WALK OUT, GIVE US YOUR QUESTIONS
IN ADVANCE.
HE IS READY TO --
[LAUGHS]
HE'S READY TO GO!
IF WE AREN'T CAREFUL LAWYERS, WE
JUST LET HIM GO.
I REMEMBER THE DEBATES THAT I
PREPARED HIM FOR IN PART WITH
CHRIS CHRISTIE.